and this was made before the thaw
between our countries how did you get it
made I mean how did you get to shoot in
Cuba well we were very diligent we had
to get a specific license from the
Treasury Department and OFAC and it took
a process of about two years and we came
from the point of view that this was a
historical reenactment of this true
story written by the writer who
experienced it itself and they first
turned us down but bob was persistent
and we had some great people in DC
helping us out and they finally gave us
approval it's opened up so much Wow but
back then it was really strict I mean
you could not shoot a movie down right
it was it was doing commerce with Cuba
and I was strictly prohibited and the
only exception they allowed were
documentaries or news gathering
journalism in essence and we made the
case that like films such as Lincoln
this was a docu-drama right and because
it was it was based on true events and
taking place in the places that they had
actually occurred we convinced the
Treasury Department that we weren't
really trying to do commerce with Cuba
we were trying to preserve these
beautiful locations that the what
happened in this story where they took
place including the Hemingway home so
that's what ultimately convinced them to
let us shoot down there how did it what
about the Cuban officials once you got
the permission from the Treasury they
welcomed you with open arms or did they
have to read and approve the script that
they have to say we need you need to
have X amount of people on your crew
they did have to approve the script but
very pleasantly I shot a film in China
called painted veil and
the censorship was unbelievable I mean
it was kind of terrible and I expected
that here but the Cubans read the script
and and I think it's because Hemingway's
so beloved in Cuba by the Cuban people
and government officials included that
once they read it they just left us
alone they didn't censor anything they
didn't ask us to not include anything or
change anything and they give us a
unprecedented support access to the
Hemingway home which they've never done
before for a feature in fact tourists
can only look through the windows they
can't go in the house Wow and so you we
were that's losing crew in there and
they gave us weapons and a communist
country I mean they're arrested on
weapons and a Coast Guard Cutter and and
they really yeah they bent over
backwards to help us when you went and
shot inside the house and use the house
did was that the actual furniture or did
you come in did your you know production
designer set decorator you know come in
and so the his house there is exactly
how Hemingway left it once he passed
away in the states they preserve they
took the museum and preserved it so
everything on the walls on the you know
cables everything is exactly the same so
that means the furniture sort of
dilapidated so we actually took most of
the furniture out and replaced it with
you know props and I guess that would
lead into a great story about Ernest
Hemingway's typewriter so we're shooting
the scene where I mean we can't write
and I'm standing on the square foot of
ground that Hemingway stood on when he
wrote yeah looking at the wall he looked
at when he wrote and they had brought
back up props for everything when I
first arrived when you first arrived on
the house on the grounds one of the
things your first struck by is the fact
that it's all women all women running
the place and there's a there's a very
sacred feeling
the grounds so when I was introduced as
the actor who was going to play
Hemingway I got one of these we shot for
a couple of days did some and they were
always around just hovering everywhere
keeping an eye on everything so we're
getting ready to shoot this scene I'm
standing there and in comes a De Rosa
who was the director of the museum and
she says we would like Adrian to work
with this and it was him i rise
typewriter oh my god so that typewriter
that you see is his typewriter this had
to have been such a passion project for
I mean all of you yourself distributed
but with with had Danny try to get this
movie made before he died 10 years ago
had had gone to various studios
producers yeah it had it actually
started shooting in Portugal when I
first got the script almost 10 years ago
when with the group that had planned it
to shoot in Portugal and when I read it
Cuba just seemed too important a
character in the film and I told them I
said you have to shoot this in Cuba and
they said well that's impossible we'll
never get done and they went off and
tried to do it in portugal and i'm not
sure what happened that it fell apart
and then then he passed away and the
rights went to his widow wanda petty
clerk and in it I chased it for two
years and finally convinced Wanda to
trust me with it because she was so
protective of it because it was Danny's
baby so to speak right it was his kind
of life story well so I mean this is
very much a father and father and son
story too I mean absolutely it is and in
it from reading you know he Jenny it was
very much like the you know the Sun you
know the Sun figure and he lost his
painting up an orphan and you were his
idol and and what he did afterwards I
mean he was the one who edited those
books and brought out islands in the
stream and wrote the screenplay to
islands in the stream and kept Hemingway
alive
you know and he actually moved to catch
him to where Wanda lives now because did
he move to catch him after him anyway
died yeah I would have been after and
Muriel is a young girl remembers Denny
she remembers this writer hanging around
the house but it wasn't until most
recently where she finally made the
connection that oh that writer was Denny
we're hanging around our family so much
well you know because you do have Muriel
and that one scene we said because you
knew her and she knew Danny that she was
willing to do what no what she said was
we were the first people to really
understand the true nature of her
grandfather she has a very very
protective feeling and rightly so about
her hand father so her choice to be a
part of this was was quite a seal of
approval on the project and on on the
portrayal of her grandfather also I you
know usually when you think of Ernest
Hemingway he's still you know the barrel
guy with the handsome with the beard and
the black hair and he's off you know in
Africa and here we see him you know
unable to write manic depressive
alcoholic it really gives you a chance
to see an artist and the pain and the
trouble that so many artists have and
still do go through Hemingway was one of
the first people to really understand
the power of a public persona of
marketing for himself this is the first
movie that deals with Hemingway at this
stage of his life yet this is the stage
of his life that ninety percent of the
people go that's Hemingway he was the
old man and the beard but it's it's
important to understand the distinction
between the two you know he wasn't as
strong or didn't have the gravitas of
the Hemingway no he didn't he was an old
man on his on his last legs and that's
that's the true story and that's the the
persona that people haven't met before
and I think that's one of the powerful
things about the film what about just
Hemingway today you know he's beloved in
Cuba you know and there are the they're
all of their some of us who you know
have read his books and I've seen the
movies and have read about him but how
is he felt looked at today I mean every
place that Hemingway has been at spent
any time in his life will say he's ours
there's a real pride in France Spain
Italy every place that he's been
Hemingway was ours you know I think he's
seen such an iconic figure I mean he's
kind of the definition of macho and
manliness for a lot of people and that's
what really fascinated me when I first
read this grip how often do you get this
very very personal insight into a
person's pain and in real life struggles
right then a guy who was there who spent
personal time and then wrote about it
and was young young and impressionable
he was still in his 20s when he met
right so it was really fascinating to
see Hemingway through these different
set of eyes with all of his flaws and
and and humanity really instead of you
know the big game hunter novelist
adventurer war correspondent that's it's
such a personal look into into the
person and the genius and how that
genius struggled